wouldn't want to have with your kid it's
like mom dad i want to take a year off
of school
but in this case what is really the best
way to make use of a gap year for your
university your college-bound son or
daughter
it's a question a lot of families are
facing now and kirsten joyce joining us
now with
some of the possibilities that are still
productive yes denise
kovet certainly changed in person
learning plans for several colleges and
universities across the u.s
and this year it made families rethink
if a remote education was worth full
tuition price
some students capitalized on the shift
to save money and withdrew from school
until further notice
so if you're in the midst of a gap year
to make the best use of your time
several things to consider first off
gauge your own health and well-being if
you're not in a great place mentally
then any school work you attempt is
going to be flawed
instead you can redefine your interests
and say community service
second consider an internship now not
later suggest former professor dr
richard de cupula
most students think i gotta wait i have
to wait until i go to college to really
start mapping this out
you can do this now and companies know
this and they're looking for students
that are maybe taking this time to say
you know what you have a lot of
intellectual capital that we can use
you know while you're trying to figure
out what to do with your day and you can
start padding your resume
finally consider keeping your academic
skills sharp by knocking out a few basic
courses online that you can then
transfer to your university when it's
time
he says he is a professor with one class
which offers booster and online classes
for credit at a reduced price and he's
seen a significant uptick in students
enrolling online
to get a jump start before next fall
brian kirsten thank you